[موسيقى]
اريد
خلقنا مجتمع فنانين خاصه بنا وننظم انشطه
بهيجه وديه وواجبات المشتركه انها اوقات
مفرحه نمضيها معا ندعو فنانين شباب من
خريجي اكاديميه الفنون فيقيمون باكوره
معارضهم ويخطون خطواتهم الاولى في عالم
الابداع وهناك جاليري اخر مخصص للمحترفين
لكننا نعيد المبتدئين في مسارهم الفني في
امكانهم استخدامه هذا المبنى برمته من اجل
الابتكار في اعمالهم وتنظيم معارض طوال
السنه وذلك مهم لنا ورائع لهم فهو مبنى
قديم له جو مميز يترك عندهم ذكريات بديعه
وشعورابابا موجود
[موسيقى]
هوشتاين
كم استغرق تشكيل جمهوريتنا قد يبدو الجواب
غريبه لكنها الحقيقه
جمهوريتنا لا تزال قائمه رغم ان وقت
تاسيسها استغرق ليله واحده فقط غيرنا وجه
هذا الحي الشعبي في ليله فصحى السكان
ووجدوا واجهات بيوتهم مختلفه عن المساء
اجل فعلناها في ساحه تمثال الملاك
الرئيسيه اعلنا بطاقه الجمهوريه
بالامس كان حيا شعبيا ومرتعا للجريمه
بنسبه تصل الى 99% اما اليوم فهو من اكثر
المناطق امانا وسلاما
في جمهوريه اذوبيس تسعى لتكون بمثابه
الجمهوريه الفاضله حيث السلام والمحبه
اذ يسعى الفنانين فيها من خلال فن الشارع
والرسم على جدران الجمهوريه لتصبح مشروعا
للوحه تشكيليه انيقه وذات اهداف ساميه
الفن في الهواء الطلق خارج قواعد عمل
الاستوديو الداخلي حول واجهات البيوت
القديمه وجدران الجمهوريه المهتدئه الى
لوحه فنيه جميله وساحره
تدفع الماره والسياح للتوقف عندها
وكانهم في معرض تشكيليه او في قاعه عرض
المسرحيه
[موسيقى]